hi I'm Eric Voss and Star Wars Episode 8
the last Jedi has its first teaser
trailer and yeah well it's more of a
teaser giving us a few cryptic clues
hinting at what the movie will be about
the last Jedi still looks great Luke
Skywalker speaks guys sure he's breaking
our hearts by telling us that Jedi have
to end but no at least the guys talking
baby steps guys and this teaser was
really well crafted with a few little
Easter eggs throughout that connect the
last Jedi to the rest of the Star Wars
universe maybe some references to the EU
as well so I'm gonna dive deep and break
down everything in this trailer frame by
frame and point out a few things that
you might have missed so let's get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
breathe
[Music]
just
[Music]
reach out
[Music]
like I think this teaser really wants us
to feel that same excitement that we
felt leading up to the force awakens
because this whole opening surprise is
definitely meant to reflect the one that
started the first force awakens teaser
there's a wide shot of a vast void as
the music builds up tension until
orchestral punch with a sweaty panicked
out of breath hero jumping into frame so
the idea is that the last Jedi will have
that same kind of suspense and surprise
that the force awakens had also this
music with the strings and bell chimes
leaving us in this mysterious state of
unrest sounds very similar to the
opening notes of the second force
awakens trailer now Ray's expression
here seems like she just came out of a
dream or a vision or something maybe
another force vision like the one she
experienced of course awakens and the
voice of Luke Skywalker instructs
suggesting a big part of this movie will
be him training her the way another
hermit Yoda
trained him in the Empire Strikes Back
we also see these beautiful wide shots
of act 2 which if you didn't know is a
real Island called skellig michael on
the southwestern coast of ireland it's
actually the location of an ancient
christian monastery and it's a protected
historical site and over this we hear
new music come in the force theme
[Music]
so this course theme is actually the
first of a few different musical themes
that this trailer all weaves together
okay so after more awesome geo porn of
Ock - and Rey looking out at the
crashing waves we hear Luke instructing
her to reach out and there's this shot
of Ray's hand levitating rocks which was
rumored to be part of the footage showed
to Disney investors last month so it
seems like Rey's training will follow
Luke's even more closely
remember Yoda made him levitate rocks -
I actually think this levitation
training will end with Rey's same hand
brakes another Rock and that opening
shot and then after Luke whispers what
the music shifts again this is Ray's
theme composed by John Williams for the
force awakens you get this shot of the
back of general Leia Organa she's
staring at this hologram star map but
let's look closely at this location the
window suggests that this is the bridge
of a battleship and I'm pretty sure
that's Admiral Ackbar in the background
there so this could be his Mon Calamari
flagship home 1 and if you listen really
closely this part they very subtly mixed
in the audio of Laius line from the very
first Star Wars chapter a new hope and
that plea for help from Leia was Luke's
first sight of his sister and this
teaser is repurposing that moment to
establish Luke's remaining force
connection with the sister even though
his exile has made her distant and faded
in his memory and by calling this image
light ray is suggesting that of all the
different parts of the force that she
could be reaching out to Leia represents
the one remaining light part of it and
we see the other side of the force as we
move on to the next section
[Music]
darkness
so this next part shifts over to the
dark side there's this mysterious shot
of what looks like the crushed helmet of
kylo Ren you can see a similar pattern
on this piece here so what happened here
whatever this is it's a mess there's a
piece of a helmet that's still smoking
so this could be the ruins of Starkiller
base even though I'm pretty sure it was
completely wiped out or slightly more
likely it could be kylos ship as he
angrily retreats from that defeat and
it's interesting to see kylos destroyed
helmet which is another echo from the
force awakens trailer which included a
shot of kylo looking at Darth Vader's
destroyed mask now kylo modeled his
helmet to show respect and admiration
for his grandfather so I think this
image here is meant to tie in to that
family connection also again the audio
plays into this with the missable sound
of Bader's iconic breathing
also you can just barely make out the
voice of obi-wan Kenobi as he tells Luke
about Anakin's fall they do is seduced
by the dark side of the force and right
before ray labels this side the force
darkness we hear the new music theme
that this trailer shifts into this is
John Williams's kylo Ren theme from the
force awakens
all right let's move on
the balance
much bigger
[Music]
okay so now that Ray has reached out to
the light side of the force and the dark
side this third image takes us somewhere
she calls and the imagery of what we see
here is a literal balance of light and
dark a beam of light streaking through
the dark surroundings now this is a
small bookshelf and the wall behind it
looks like the roots of a tree now in
past Star Wars videos that we've done
we've talked about how in the expanded
universe novel shattered Empire Luke
Skywalker tracks down to force sensitive
trees that once grew under the Jedi
Temple in course on and one of those
streets gets planted in the home of Poe
Dameron which might explain why he's
such a great pilot meanwhile maybe the
other force tree could be part of the
roots that we're seeing here like Luke
planted it on this island now I doubt
that the last Jedi will bring in that eu
theory into this movie but it could be a
reference to it now so what exactly are
these books when Ray looks at one of the
pages we see this symbol this is a
symbol of the Jedi Order I always love
this image especially how it uses the
lightsaber flare imagery from that
original Star Wars poster and I'm
guessing that Luke was able to recover
all these old texts from around the
galaxy like maybe in the ruins of that
jedi temple and under this you can just
barely hear the voice of Yoda from
Empire Strikes Back its energy surrounds
us and binds us
there's also the sound of a lightsaber
powering up now this balance that they
refer to between light and dark sides of
the force has been kind of a classic
dualism at the heart of the entire Star
Wars saga
but what Luke says here suggests that
the last Jedi will go much deeper than
this conflict so there's a few ways that
we can interpret Luke's words here some
of them are sexual so let's just ignore
those for now I said ignore they're also
a few things in the expanded universe
that could help explain this one is the
concept of grey Jedi or grey knights now
a grey Jedi is a Jedi who walks the line
between the light and the dark sides of
the force without surrendering to the
dark side it also refers to Jedi who
distance themselves from the Jedi High
Council and operate outside of the Jedi
Code and one example is a character Joe
lead Bindo from the Knights of the Old
Republic game there's also been some
debate over whether qui-gon jinn was a
great Jedi then again some people at the
Lucasfilm story group have rejected this
idea saying that the dark side isn't
meant to give a Jedi edge or make him
more of a badass it's meant to be a
binary opposite with a real cost but
still I could see how this idea
influences where Luke is at right now
like he saw how there was still good in
his father even after he surrendered to
the dark side and later his attempts to
bring back the old dogmatic Jedi Order
and traditions led to the disaster of
his nephew Ben becoming kylo Ren so just
like how the color of Luke's clothes
gradually changed throughout the films
starting white but then becoming
increasingly darker as he became closer
to his father and then back to these
gray mid-tones maybe the concept of the
grey Jedi is influencing Luke
subconsciously in his exile like it
could just be his experiences have led
Luke to seeing things not in black and
white with the force but more in shades
of grey okay I didn't say 50 shades of
grey the other possible EU influence on
Luke here comes from the figure Ben do
from Star Wars rebels so bindu is a
massive ancient moose looking creature
with camouflage z-bar
skin he's definitely force sensitive and
it can do a lot of things that Jedi
can't even do but he claims to be
neither light nor dark but in the middle
actually the word Bindu is a deep
throwback to George Lucas's original
script for a new hope where the original
name for Jedi was Jedi Bindu and some
people are suggesting that so much
bigger could be referring to Ben dus
massive size and that the surface behind
the bookshelf is Ben dudes bark skin but
now I'm really leaning against Ben do or
gray Jedi turning up in this movie
literally but I do think the philosophy
behind them is true for Luke like the
old simple duality of the Star Wars saga
isn't true for him anymore
and before I move on this shot of Rey
training with Luke's lightsaber on the
cliffside features a few interestingly
shaped rock formations like one as a
camera pans around the cliff and another
next to Rey like these might just be
boulders but they definitely look human
shaped right like I'm wondering if the
one next to Rey will end up being some
kind of monument that Luke made in the
shape of obi-wan or Anakin or Yoda or
just up folder let's move on
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so here the teaser kicks in a gear
first are these shots of I'm guessing
resistance fighters as they speed across
this remote planet called crate and are
flying towards first-order walkers and
those have been nicknamed gorilla
walkers since they're larger with bigger
sturdier front arms firmly planted in
the ground and probably because we're
too eager to shoot them our AP Harambee
now what are these fighters doing at
first I thought they were released
seeing plumes of red smoke like sky
rider planes but no they're actually
using these anchors to scrape the ground
kicking up this bright red soil now I'm
not sure exactly why they're doing it
but my guess is that they're kicking up
dirt as a smokescreen effect like maybe
making it harder for the walkers to
target them and this red color is such
an interesting visual choice for a
planet in a Star Wars movie like we
don't normally see non earthy colors or
places that couldn't possibly exist
somewhere on earth and Bryan Johnson
said that crate is the location of an
old rebel base where red mineral sand is
covered in a white dusty salt surface so
maybe this red is caused by oxidized
rusted metal particles in the soil we
also get this quick shot of Finn who
looks like he's still recovering in some
kind of medical pod remember he left his
fight with kylo Ren pretty messed up and
in case we were wondering someone
actually translated the Arabic letters
on the screen there and while some of it
just translated to nonsense the word
here means stable so I guess he's okay
also look at the corners of the frames
that flashing blue light kind of looks
like hyperspace to me
so I know this sounds crazy but maybe
thin is being sent through hyperspace in
his own portable medical escape pod
which might explain why he has this
additional shell over his body which
would like protect them from turbulence
now I don't know if that's even possible
with Star Wars technology like this pod
would need its own hyperdrive right
seems excessive like I can buy
interstellar escape pods for Kryptonians
but less so for cash-strapped resistance
soldiers still this could mean that
wherever Finn was recovering ended up
under attack so that his body had to be
hastily sent off like this and I'm
guessing that attack is what we're
seeing in these next few shots with poe
and bb-8 there's an explosion and a
resistance hangar that nearly engulfed
suppose black x-wing and if you look
over to the left
those two engines
along to an a wing which we get a quick
glimpse of later on in this teaser but
let's move on I only know one truth
[Music]
so here there's more action with the
Millennium Falcon and a dogfight with
Tie Fighters and I'm interested to see
who's piloting the Falcon here
considering it won't be done so I don't
know if this means ray will be taking
the wheel now or Chewie or maybe we'll
get a little cameo from mr. Billy Dee
Williams now I know they said Lando
wouldn't be in this movie but come on my
kid can drink and after shots of Rey
running with Luke's lightsaber and kylo
Ren menacingly twisting his same blade
which I guess he still has along with
that scar that Rey gave them we get this
interesting shot of Luke and r2d2
looking at this burning structure
actually this shot looks like it's part
of that same mystery scene that Rey saw
in her force vision and that burning
building looks a lot like a Jedi Temple
with a central pyramid so we're probably
gonna see this event in the last Jedi
possibly a flashback to win
kylo turned on Luke I also like how this
visual parallels Luke returning home to
find another flaming pile of ashes in
the shape of his aunt and uncle in a new
hope man I really hope Lucas homeowners
insurance really though I think these
tragic homecomings are meant to be
connected to characterize Luke as a
wanderer disconnected from his home and
then in a different fiery location we
get a quick shot of Captain phasma
as she marches in with first-order
soldiers I feel like this could be that
same resistance hangar after the attack
and phasma has arrived
probably in search of that traitorous
fn-2187 who forced her inside a trash
compactor and Starkiller base there's
also some quick but amazing space battle
shots with these new looking resistance
frigates forming a line as x-wings and
Tie Fighters take each other out there's
also a quick shot of an a wing and let's
move on to this final part time
July to end
[Music]
Wow okay I don't know about you but I
was like ooh time for the Jedi to what
return late that's already movie title
to kick some ass party down to end Luke
you're breaking my heart
Daisy Ridley actually described Ray's
since a disappointment here she said Ray
has a certain expectation as to what she
might be getting from Luke it's
difficult when you meet your heroes so
it sounds like when this movie picks
back up on that shot with Rey returning
Luke's lightsaber to him his reaction
might be something more like sorry good
ain't the Jedi that I used to be get off
my Island
of course this all makes sense because
this is the last Jedi but now this
teaser has given us more context to what
that means for Luke this perennial
conflict within the force with the light
Jedi on one side and the dark sit on the
other hasn't really given him the
balance or answers that he's been
seeking and I think he's suggesting here
that in order to end the Sith the Jedi
must also end and that involves moving
beyond the old dogma of the Jedi Order
into a more complex pluralistic view of
the force which this final shot reflects
showing Luke exiting the cave entering a
more enlightened world okay so those are
all the things that I noticed in this
first teaser for the last Jedi but I'm
sure we'll see even more footage and set
photos in the coming months that will
clear a lot of this stuff up along with
the rest of the cast like chewy and
Threepio Andros
calimary trans characters and hopefully
Snoke but come on guys Snoke is everyone
right isn't that what the theory is we
do a ton of Star Wars coverage I
actually did a super in-depth rogue one
breakdown that and you should go check
out if you haven't already and if you
like this video please hit like and
subscribe for new rock stars and share
this video around you can also
contribute to us on patreon thanks so
much to all of our current patrons you
guys are all great especially Wilhelmina
eveson you can hit me up on twitter at
EA vas with any thoughts or predictions
you have on the last Jedi or follow new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
for updates on their videos all right
thanks for watching bye
[Music]